I routinely show people how to negotiate
10 $25,000 raises all the time and
you're like that's crazy there's no way
at cetera etc excuse-excuse here's the
different approach wanna be happy build
a life not just the business hey it's
Evan Carmichael and this channel was
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today that's live your best believe
life and learn how to ask for and get a
big raise also if you want to have more
confidence and self-love check out my
254 series they're free the links join
on the description below you have to
work with people where you feel a bit
insecure that's essential because that
means you're working with people who are
better than you you want people with a
like mind and that are better than you
smarter than you
more intelligent than you to get on your
bus you have to go build self-confidence
ok let's learn how to get the raise be a
top performer with Ramat safety let's
talk about the job stuff because I talk
about jobs it's a little unusual I think
that it's become very popular online to
say like screw jobs and like be an
entrepreneur and I think
entrepreneurship is great but I also
think most people have a job and you can
create amazing value by working with a
team and I have employees and they do an
incredible job so and I've had jobs so I
think that when it comes to a job there
is a totally counterintuitive way to
approach it
I mean Lee show people how to negotiate
10 $25,000 raises all the time and
you're like that's crazy there's no way
at cetera etc excuse-excuse here's the
different approach the first way that
most people think is like if I'm gonna
negotiate for a raise which like oh they
might just like fire me that's problem
number one that's that's the wrong way
to look at it if you go in and ask for a
raise you're not devaluing yourself
you're actually increasing your value
because what type of person would go in
and ask for a raise a top performer so
the second thing is they believe that
they have to kick
the door of their boss and say like
gimme money well if you do that of
course they're gonna kick you out that's
a very impolite way to do it a third way
is much more effective so I'll just give
you like the quick lay of the land if
you want to get a raise for anybody
watching this is how you do it you send
an email to your boss you say you know
what I would love to meet with you and I
would love to discuss what it takes to
be an absolute top performer in this
world to make your life easier could we
set up sometime in the next week or two
of course 100% of bosses are gonna say
yes I'd love to see you so you go in
there and you say hey boss really
appreciate you taking the time I've
enjoyed my role I just want to tell you
that I don't want to just do a fine job
I want to be a top performer here and I
would love to know exactly what it takes
for me to be a top performer okay so let
me just pause right here if I'm the
employee and you're the boss how do you
feel right now
with me walking in and asking this so
good like this is the greatest advice of
all time okay because we're creating
value right and I'm not coming in saying
like give me money I'm like please
advise me you're the boss I want to
learn from you so the boss is gonna say
they're gonna give you some generic
answer because they weren't prepared for
this oh you need to show up and blah
blah blah blah but whatever you say I
really appreciate that
I'd love to get really specific in fact
I did a little bit of research before I
came in here are three things I think
would be look at that look at that face
because bosses don't hear this most of
their employees just show up do what's
expected and then they're like how come
I'm not getting a $10,000 raise lycra
meet said cuz you don't deserve $10,000
unless you go above and beyond so you
know hey boss I know that I'm currently
working on this sales project and we're
slated to have a 3% improvement I really
think we can do six would that be part
of top performing role here yes what
about this that it so you you have a
little discussion and you say okay am I
reading this right these three things
would help me really outperform at this
role yes okay I'll tell you what I'd
like to get to work on this I'm gonna
commit to sending you an update every
week or every two weeks and at the end
of six months I'd like to come back and
show you what I accomplished if I do it
I'd like to discuss a salary adjustment
at that time but let's not even worry
about that right now
let's have me focus on this what do you
say
yeah yeah okay right so so this is so
this is the first conversation now I go
back to my desk I send a written record
every Friday I'm sending an update
here's where we are blah blah blah now
the time comes six months from now and
by the way this is true for negotiating
a raise it's true for dating and
relationships it's true for
Entrepreneurship all the work is done
before you ever set foot in the room
ironically everyone fixates on going in
the room what are the fancy words it's
like yeah I'll show you the words but
all the work is done before that's what
every successful person knows so I send
another email now and I say you know
what as you know I've been updating you
every week for the last four and a half
months I have some fantastic results
you know we hit this we hit that I'd
love to come in and present the whole
thing to you can we set up some time yes
so now I go in by the way I've done my
homework
and I've done it in a couple of ways
that nobody else does number one I've
researched my compensation so let's say
I'm being paid 50k but I researched my
salary on salary comp a scale and I
discover you know my range should
actually be 56 to 62 okay good I'm
writing that down second I have a couple
of my co-workers and I go to them I say
hey you know we've worked together on
this project I would really appreciate
it if you would send a an email to the
boss and just say you know what we meats
been doing an incredible job he really
helped drive this process through and
get us that 6.2 percent conversion
increase so now I walk in you've got
those emails you're like this is the
greatest employee on earth I walk in I
say you know what I'm so proud we
accomplished this we accomplished that
we discussed this six months ago I
wanted to be a top performer here you go
you theatrically pull out your results
out of your briefcase the it matters to
be theatric right and then how's the
boss feeling right now
amazing amazing everybody's happy you
winning you're doing your boss's job for
them they're happy and then you say you
know there's one last thing I know we
discussed having a discussion about a
compensation adjustment I'd like to talk
about that right now now you get to have
the conversation you've got all your
data you've already made the boss a ton
of money and all the words you can use
are right there in the book and on my
courses that's how
you negotiate your salary so when people
say like oh there's no way I can
negotiate yeah there's no way if you
just walk in and say give me money but
if you actually become a top performer
then it makes perfect sense that you
would get top performer compensation my
crop man yeah now I have a special bonus
clip from Robin Sharma on how to
over-deliver that I think you can enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to take an
action here we go question number one
how can you be a better performer number
two how can you bring more value to your
boss or to your customers and number
three what's gonna make you so good that
they can't ignore you and if you made it
this far in the video I want to
celebrate you give me a hashtag believe
down the comments you're in a restaurant
the server generally gives you what you
expect or less than what you expect you
go into a clothing store it's what you
expect or less than what you expect you
do business with any organization it's
generally delivering on what you expect
but more often even less so you have a
gorgeous opportunity to lead the field
in everything that you do by doing one
thing practicing every single day
because it's a muscle the ritual of
over-delivering don't just give your
customers what they expect give them 10x
more than what they expect don't just
give your organization what your manager
what your boss what the organization is
expecting from you show something that
is so rare in today's economy initiative
initiative so you're asked to do a
project give them five more things than
they expect you're asked to give a
presentation on something go the extra
mile
consistently dial in the daily habit of
over delivering on people's expectations
and guess what you become a merchant of
wow you become indispensable to your
organization I wrote a book a little
while ago called the greatness guide and
one of the chapters talked about the
importance of being indispensable and I
learned that when I was a young lawyer
and I remember talking to my mentor and
I asked my mentor you know the top
litigator at this firm how come he is
the icon of the legal profession in this
region and my mentor looked at me and
said Robin because that person is
indispensable to this firm well how do
you do that by practicing the ritual of
over delivering every single day for the
rest of your life if you want to see
Dane piñas most brutal rants ever check
out their video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there this is
what I'm training you to be like the
four horsemen of them in Apocalypse as
soon as we got tougher as soon as we got
less PC